[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué harías
si por decisión de otros o por malas
decisiones de otros fueras tú
completamente el afectado
esta pregunta quizás no es tan difícil
de contestar las quizás la podemos
contestar con afirmación positividad
puesto que en gran medida muchos
de los que han estado asociados a
nuestra vida fueron e hicieron con
nosotros los primeros años de nuestras
vidas
a menudo pienso en la cantidad de
elecciones decisiones que tomamos al día
muchas de esas decisiones son cotidianas
son simples por ejemplo
si la abono la voy díaz la ropa si salgo
con los compas y si veo no una serie de
netflix hoy día o me duermo son hay
muchas decisiones cotidianas en el día
pero también hay otra decisión es
importante que nos pueden perseguir por
el resto la vida por ejemplo
cuando no se ha sabido controlar las
emociones de la juventud y nos hemos
convertido en padres jóvenes
la universidad de columbia hizo un
estudio sobre las decisiones y de belo
que tomamos alrededor de 70 decisiones
importantes al día
entonces como tomamos tantas decisiones
importantes entidades estaban generando
también nuestra realidad
como le añadimos significado a estas
decisiones que tomamos al día porque
estás de alguna forma van escribiendo la
historia de nuestra vida
del 2001 a 2003
tuve una interesante oportunidad de
servir dos años
en servicio al semejante en servicio al
prójimo en el norte argentina
dos años que me sirvieron como una clase
magistral para mi vida una clase
magistral que necesitaría para el resto
mi vida para entender cómo abordar los
momentos más críticos de mi vida
en el año 2001 argentina entraba en una
de sus más grandes crisis económicas que
hasta el día de hoy tiene ecos hasta el
día de hoy tiene secuelas esa crisis
fue una crisis que generó una profunda
escasez de alimentos una profunda
conmoción social una profunda
vulneración de la seguridad
y esta crisis fue provocada por
consecuencia de algunos y como como
decisión de unos pocos
muchos fueron afectados
recuerdo que como vi a una profunda
necesidad de alimentos
había por ende pues muertes a diarios de
niños de infantes puedes imaginar ir por
una calle
y ver en una calle de una ciudad del
norte argentina tucumán por ejemplo
imagínate ir por una calle
y escuchar a madres que salen de sus
casas llorando la pérdida de sus hijos
y que te buscan a ti como una especie de
salvador para ver si tú puedes traer a
la vida nuevamente a ese hijo que se le
fue por causa del hambre
puedes imaginar eso
para una persona como yo que en ese
tiempo tenía tan solamente 20 años
los niños más grandes
acudían a basureros a buscar dentro de
la cantidad de comida descompuesta la
mejor comida dentro de la composición
nada más para poder satisfacer su
necesidad principal que era el hambre
te puedes imaginar ir caminando
por calles aledañas a una ciudad donde
están los vertederos los basureros y ver
montañas de basura y ver niños
escarbando para encontrar lo mejor de lo
podrido lo mejor de esa pudrición para
comer
yo el gordo que ese día
con un llanto que no podía controlar
tuve que ir a comprar una caja de
alfajores que es un dulce argentino
y llamar a esos niños y si la gente come
de basura vengan y como en algo un poco
mejor que la basura
otra persona simplemente mataba en todo
tipo de animales todo tipo de animales
gatos perros para simplemente sacar la
carne y comerla
esta crisis fue conocida como la crisis
del corralito
que hasta el día de hoy tiene secuelas
en mi llamada argentina
el año 2001 era la primera vez en que yo
salía fuera de mi casa estaba lejos de
una vida tranquila lejos de una vida en
casa de una vida con mis padres en una
vida tranquila donde tenía todo donde
tenía donde no me faltaba nada
y donde en ese hecho como no me faltaba
nada
yo tampoco era una persona agradecida
por lo que tenía era más bien algo
ingrato
no podía entender el ser agradecido por
simplemente tener un calzado unas tenis
de buena calidad
entonces este tiempo de vida fue para mí
una clase magistral en uno de los
escenarios más tristes que puede vivir
un ser humano
recuerdo un verano de enero del año 2002
en una provincia del norte argentina que
se llama jujuy en una ciudad bueno en un
pueblito chiquito que se llama monte
rico
recuerdo que en ese tiempo
conocí a una familia
a un padre que hace unos días atrás o
bueno semanas atrás había perdido a su
esposa
además de la crisis económica había
perdido su esposa
y tenía niños en ese tiempo pequeños
te imaginas cómo enfrentar una crisis de
ese tipo una crisis psicológica porque
te llevas un dolor que tú no puedes
calcular porque perdiste a tu esposa
y como además abordar una realidad para
enfrentar una crisis económica porque si
no comes te mueres
yo recuerdo aquí
es tenía
un carro viejo muy viejo
en donde pues ya estaba abandonado
porque estaba viejo
un motor de cuatro cilindros les
funcionaba en tres porque el otro no lo
tenía
ya estaba todo está armado y él dijo
este padre familia él dijo algo tengo
que hacer para abordar esta crisis
necesito generar ingresos un éxito
general lana
y a ese pistón que le faltaba el motor
él es un pistón de madera
arreglo el carro por dentro como pudo a
sus recursos que pudo
y tenía un tarro de pintura y tenía una
brocha y pintó de amarillo ese carro
viejo y lo convirtió en especie de taxi
lo que para muchos poder sido una
estupidez lo que para muchos puede ser
una tontería una invisibilidad o cómo se
te ocurre y el qué dirán el que va a ser
el vecino
el famoso qué dirán él eligió crear una
condición diferente
él eligió ante la adversidad crear una
circunstancia diferente para su vida y
él convirtió ese carro viejo en un taxi
y gracias a ese hecho y de lo poco que
generaba como ingreso para movilizar
personas nada más le alcanzaba a generar
ingresos
para juntar para un plato de arroz
para un plato de arroz sin nada
acompañándole nada de carne nada de eso
entonces yo se siente mi
inmenso fue como nunca pude agradecer lo
mínimo que me llegará a vivir
la comida diaria el tener zapatos es
tener ropa
y el estar en un lugar tranquilo
el tener que quejarme porque si no me
tenían x comida pues yo simplemente me
molestaba o simplemente no comía
entonces tuve que vivir esa realidad de
forma abrupta
para entender que el ser humano necesita
de crisis'
en mayor y menor escala
para entender cómo alteramos nuestra
realidad
de hecho entendí con las decisiones que
ese hombre tomó de que las crisis son
oportunidades profundas cubiertas
encubiertas para poder detonar potencial
de oportunidad de potencial de
creatividad potencial de innovar
potencial de poder hacer un app un
posicionamiento diferente para tu vida
fue para mí una bofetada de enseñanzas
el haber pasado por estos momentos
a lo largo de mi vida he vivido pues
muchas circunstancias difíciles
por supuesto no como la que viví en
argentina no ese nivel
pero de lo que viví no cierto rescate
que de la crisis o de los escenarios más
complejos la vida uno puede sacar
enseñanzas que perduran y que pueden
convertirse en un faro
y determinantes para ver cómo abordar tu
vida en momentos de crisis
un filósofo de la antigüedad epícteto
dijo la vida no es lo que nos sucede
sino lo que hacemos con aquello que nos
sucede
entonces las elecciones abren caminos
siempre a veces en mi afán por querer
ayudar o en mi deseo por querer ayudar a
alguien que está pasando por una crisis
yo le digo esa persona no te resignes no
no te agua es bueno tener noticias al
suelo o la vida así y por lo general
ellos me dicen es que tú no me entiendes
es que tú no estás en mis zapatos es que
tú no estás en mi cinturón en mis
pantalones
y yo pienso entre mí y comparte una
persona que por cierto si estoy
he vivido lo que tú has vivido por eso
que tengo una sugerencia por último
moral para poder decirte que si se puede
si no tienes la capacidad
para cambiar algo acéptalo pero si
tienes el poder para hacer algo hazlo tú
estás tú
qué hacemos
cuando ya pasó la ola que hacemos cuando
se nos avienta el chaparrón que hacemos
cuando
es escenario gris llega a nuestra vida
nos levantamos seguimos quejándonos
ese hombre a pesar de que tenían niños
chicos en ese momento podía
perfectamente haber culpado al gobierno
o podían inculpado cualquier cosa pero
él simplemente eligió crear algo
diferente él se hizo cargo de su
situación él dijo yo no puedo morirme de
hambre mis hijos no pueden morir de
hambre
no puede el dolor de haber perdido de
haber perdido mi esposa ser un detonante
para no darle sentido mi vida
y él creó el eligió el poder de elegir
él lo entendió allí
él eligió algo diferente para darle un
contexto y un sentido poderoso a la vida
de forma diferente
por lo tanto cuando tenemos estos
chaparrones en la vida a estas estas
tormentas que a veces nos duelen y
muchísimos que hacemos con él pasamos a
los demás
culpamos a algo
porque la primera tendencia al ser
humano es culpar a algo oa alguien yo
tengo la culpa
adoptamos esa actitud nos hacemos cargo
nos levantamos ponemos la otra mejilla y
vamos por más
entonces
no digo que ignoremos los problemas que
nos suceden
simplemente quiero decir de que nosotros
le atribuimos un valor a lo que nos
sucede
nosotros le atribuimos significado algo
que no sucede
cuando estamos pasando por un momento de
crisis
son tres cosas las que tenemos que tener
cuidado siempre
las palabras tus pensamientos son los
que determinan la situación en la que tú
vives por ejemplo si te han echado el
trabajo pues te echaron de trabajo no
pasa nada
no te mataron no te quitaron la vida te
cortaron los brazos te sacaron el
cerebro no te echaron de trabajo pero
son tus pensamientos sobre lo que te
sucede lo que determina cómo piensas al
respecto
y cómo piensas al respecto son tus
palabras las que también van
determinando cómo que te dices a ti
mismo sobre lo que te sucede
y tus pensamientos
y tus palabras determinan a las finales
cómo vas creando tu realidad de vida
en mis últimos años de experiencia
profesional en mi vida personal luego de
muchas caídas luego luego de muchos
altos y bajos
luego de fracasos
luego de éxitos luego de caídas luego de
dolores
y aprendió cuatro principios de poder
que se han convertido en una especie de
brújula para mi vida
lo primero nunca te resignes
si puedes hacer algo para cambiar tu
pelea
cámbialo
si no puedes hacer nada aceptaron
lo segundo es que las cosas sucedan
cuando entendemos que tenemos un poder
para elegir
en todos los ámbitos de la vida en todos
los ámbitos de la vida en todos los
ámbitos al despertar que la costar al
conversar y al pensar en todos los
ámbitos profundos interno y externo de
la vida
nosotros somos finalmente el responsable
para hacer que las cosas sucedan en
nuestra vida
con este conocimiento de que tenemos una
capacidad maravillosa para elegir ya no
podemos culpar a nada ni a nadie
nosotros somos los autores de cómo
queremos diseñar nuestras vidas
lo tercero es
las circunstancias son como son ninguna
circunstancia es buena o es mala
simplemente es
nada más depende pues del contexto o del
significado que tú le das es como tú vas
a guardar tus realidades
cubiertos pensamientos
porque tus pensamientos van a cuidar tus
palabras y tus palabras van a determinar
para el resto de tu vida tus acciones
y por último no escribes los errores
hoy por hoy estamos en una cultura que
todo el léxico que a brillar que álex
pero si tics o sea no siempre es así
no podemos pretender dejar afuera los
errores por buscar esa perfección
sublime que nos exige la sociedad porque
si tú pretendes o si pretendemos dejar
afuera los errores vamos a dejar también
afuera la verdad
por lo tanto hoy día
cuando va todo bien en mi vida se más
extraño no estar pasando ya una crisis
porque son las crisis las que han
determinado profundamente el sentido de
mi vida
por lo tanto ninguna circunstancia
es bueno mala es transitoria y depende
el significado que tú le des el cómo vas
a orientar tu vida y le vas a dar el
significado a tu vida en lo que resta de
tu pasar por este maravilloso tiempo
gracias
[Aplausos]